adriano juega un juego que involucra a
disparar dos tiros libres la siguiente
tabla muestra la distribución de x el
número de disparos que hace adrián en
sus dos intentos junto con algunas
estadísticas aquí está la variable
aleatoria x que es una variable
aleatoria discreta ya que solo puede
tomar un número finito de valores solo
puede tomar el valor de 0 1 o 2 la
probabilidad de que logres 0 tiros está
aquí de que logré un tiro está aquí y de
que logré los dos tiros está aquí
también nos dan la media de x y la
desviación estándar de x nos preguntan
si el juego cuesta 15 pesos y él gana 10
pesos por cada tiro exitoso cuál es la
media y la desviación estándar de su
ganancia neta al jugar n vamos a definir
una nueva variable aleatoria n que es
igual a su ganancia neta podemos definir
n en términos de x cuál será su ganancia
neta n va a ser igual a 10 por la
cantidad de tiros que logró x y sin
importar el resultado él tiene que pagar
15 pesos para jugar así que a esto le
restamos 15
escribir una tabla para la distribución
de probabilidades de n n es igual a la
ganancia neta aquí abajo tenemos la
probabilidad de n y tenemos tres
posibles resultados el resultado que
corresponde a que no logré tiro alguno
es 10 x 0 menos 15 y tendremos una
ganancia de menos 15 con la misma
probabilidad de punto 16 cuando él logra
un tiro la ganancia neta es 10 por 1
menos 15 que es igual a menos 5 que
tiene la misma probabilidad 0.48 la
probabilidad de que logre un tiro es de
48% y esta será la misma probabilidad de
que él tenga una ganancia neta de menos
5 finalmente cuando él logra los dos
tiros la ganancia neta es de 10 por 2
menos 15 lo que nos da igual a 5 la
probabilidad de que logre dos tiros en
ese punto 36 nos piden encontrar la
media y la desviación estándar de la
ganancia neta calculemos primero la
media de n si escalamos una variable
aleatoria la media correspondiente
estará
por la misma cantidad y si desplazamos
una variable aleatoria la media
correspondiente será desplazada la misma
cantidad la media de n va a ser diez
veces la media de x menos 15 que es
igual a 10 por 1.2 menos 15 1215 nos da
menos 3 la desviación estándar de n va a
ser algo diferente en la desviación
estándar importa mucho la escala si
escalamos la variable aleatoria por
cierta cantidad también escalamos la
desviación estándar por la misma
cantidad esto es igual a 10 por la
desviación estándar de x y ustedes me
pueden preguntar qué pasa con este
desplazamiento el desplazamiento no
afecta a la dispersión de la variable
aleatoria si escalamos la variable
aleatoria la dispersión también varía de
acuerdo a esta cantidad pero el
desplazarla no afecta qué tan dispersa
se encuentra de la media así pues la
desviación estándar solo es afectada por
el escalamiento pero no por el
desplazamiento esto es 10 por punto 69
nos da 6.9 que es
aproximación esta es la nueva
distribución para la ganancia neta ésta
es la media y esta es la desviación
estándar aproximada de la ganancia neta